uh we had ourselves a match of 60o
performances andb went for 70 last night
Carl Anthony towns was 62 in a very
surprising L we haven't seen two 60o
performances on the same night since
1978 and is 45 years ago David Thompson
George gerin before that 16 years Jerry
Wester Wilt Chamberlain and a year
before yeah Wilt Wilt did it again I I
looked it up I was looking at the 70
point performances wilt had won on
November 3rd he had 72 versus the Lakers
and then 13 days later he had 73 against
the Knicks but unbelievable for Joel
embiid to do that um you did a a thing
recently about the big man Alliance and
I had some producers telling me that you
didn't have Aid in the big man Alliance
so welcome to the big man Alliance Joker
and people were like where is embiid are
you ready to say right now that embiid
is in the big Mani when he wins to get
automatic entrance to the Big Man line
see you need a championship you need a
champ I did not know that why is youing
on there let me finish you need I was
just wondering or a large body of work
okay so he's working his way towards
listen last night we was sending a
message to the young fell he was sending
a message to Joker he was sending a
message to me he was sending a message
to the world and saying I am the best
center in the league however in this
world that we live in and this game we
play we must get past the second round
into Eastern Conference Championship and
a winner Championship to solidify this
year gotcha as my Uncle Jerome used to
say you can score 50 60 and 70 but if
you watching somebody else play for the
championship what does it all mean is is
he the leader right now for MVP oh yeah
all day he's in that right yeah all day
every since December 1st he is shooting
57% 42% from three and 90% from the free
he's trying to get in the big man
Alliance in the club listen when it's
all set done he will definitely be in
there okay all right right good uh 16
and2 the Sixers are since Thanksgiving
with embiid uh and he scored 70 in 37
minutes which is the fewest minutes it's
ever taken to score 70 he was on fire
last night it was couldn't miss and he
did it with 1 three and he could have
had more points to be honest like if he
stays in that game if he if the record
is not an issue and he just wants to
stay in there he could have got four or
six more points easy like the way he was
rolling it was easy and they were in the
bonus on free throws I texted you guys
because it was against wemi and people
were like oh how's the Rivalry going to
be and it brought you back to a time
earlier when in your career with a big
rookie taking you on for the first time
well I think sometimes it's about that
competition right like you are an
established player in the league as
embid was uhoh similar uhoh like Stewie
coming in the league she won four
national championships CP you welcome
Stewie but I didn't welcome him like
embiid embiid has 70 what you do this
game I don't even remember I I 30 yeah I
had 34 there go
oh they call the offensive F that they
off but but I think as a established
Center in the league ID there's
sometimes you got to prove yourself and
you got to say like I understand wmy
you're here but it's still my time we
seen Steph do it time and time again to
Trey young who is the future you know of
the future of carrying on the
three-point shots so I I just sat back
and watched greatness last night because
I think the game is in great hands we're
talking about embiid which we should he
had 70 but wimy had 33 yeah so I think
the game is not good enough you said
what W's 33 see I'm talking about just
Shaq he's going against a potential two
time I don't care you can't let nobody
hit 70 on you now this is null and void
I don't want to hear that what's the
most you giv up me you I'm not known for
defense I don't
know your offense was your defense
listen he he had a good game but I don't
want to hear oh he had 30 no you can't
let a man get 70 on have you ever seen
somebody like Drop 50 and then the next
night you were like I need to go big to
Oh all the time I used to like when I
was uh chasing the scoring titles I
would always pay attention to David
Robinson uh you know all obvious you
know guys guys like that how about you
I've seen it once okay what was the
situation situation was my brother
Brandon Roy you know in Seattle we all
root for each other but it's the
competitive thing and and he pushed me I
would like to think I pushed him and he
scored 52 against the Suns I waited a
day and then did it again score
50 yeah it was a game within the game it
was a game within the game so the whole
day leading up to it you were like I
need to yeah he had 52 and I he was
getting too close I only had one 50
point game at that time I believe no I
had two and I said okay he got one now I
got to get one and the next night I went
back and got 50 nobody knows this story
this is untold stories right here un
untold stories no one knows if that's
the reason you were motivated that's the
reason I was motivated I got a story to
tell you about my red Ferrari one day
save that for later did you call up
Brandon Roy if you guys knew what we
talked about in the commercials did you
call up Brandon Roy afterwards and be
like I got you he sent me a text after
and he sent me a smiley face and I sent
him back a wink so we knew what it was
yeah absolutely the game what year was
this you were 200 2008 2008 did they
have Smiley fa in 2008 oo yeah they
did
they Ser might
I didn't say I sent skates I said I sent
a smiley
face face em back
then